hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
so have any of you been feeling uh
depressed
sad angry you know it's been a tough
year 2020 right
uh although maybe some of you have been
doing well in your own personal
ventures so maybe you're happy maybe
you're joyful
maybe you're cautiously optimistic what
we're talking about here are
emotions we all have them emotions are
very important for
who we are how we live our lives but in
the study of neuroscience or in how we
think about psychology it's possible to
argue that emotions get a little bit of
short shrift
right we talk about consciousness we
talk about neurons we talk about
cognition and so forth
but emotions are clearly very important
but they have something of a
a wishy-washy connotation right i mean
they sort of float over what is
important about the brain which is how
we think and reason and so forth
today's guest lisa feldman barrett wants
to push back against that a little bit
she's a psychologist at northeastern
university and the developer of
something called the theory of
constructed emotion
if i can put into my own words uh you'll
hear lisa's words during the podcast but
in previous episodes of mindscape we've
talked a lot about neuroscience in the
brain and two things have become clear
to me anyway one is the fact that the
brain is part of the body
right the fact that our sensory inputs
and how we feel in our physical form
is crucially important to what we think
of as thinking not just the neurons that
are locked in our brain
and the other thing is that our brain
constructs models of the world and tries
to predict what will happen next so we
know
what to do we know how to make choices
how to live in the world so
lisa feldman barrett wants to make the
case that emotions play a crucial role
in both of these aspects of what it
means to be thinking
that emotions are not fundamental
actually in fact she doesn't put it this
way but i would say emotions are
emergent
there is no emotion circuit in the brain
and there's
certainly not specific you know anger
circuits or happiness circuits or
anything like that
there are affects in the brain we feel
strongly about something or weakly about
something
positively about something or negatively
about something but emotions are
kind of coarse graining their ways of
conceptualizing these effective
responses to turn them
into action to decide what we should do
next how we should actually respond to
what is going on
out there in the world so emotions are
not hardwired they're things that are
constructed and they're things that we
can sort of
alter and change in various ways but
they're absolutely crucial to the
functioning of how we live
in the world you know david hume who's
been cited on the podcast many times
uh once famously pointed out that reason
is and always should be the slave
of the passions meaning that it's our
passions our emotions if you want to put
it that way
that give us motivation that tell us
what we want to do
and reason follows along and tells us
how to get
to what we want but it's the emotions
it's the passions that actually decide
what it is we want so
they're a big deal we should take them
seriously we should do the science
necessary
to understand where emotions come from
how they relate to the actions we take
and what they do living in the brain and
we're gonna do that
so let's go
lisa feldman barrett welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks so much for
having me on your podcast
sure uh one of the things you have a new
book out
seven and a half lessons about the brain
and i was very interested to learn
one of the lessons is that i only have
one brain
and i i guess i thought i knew that but
apparently there's an alternative people
think you have more than one brain
well there is this pervasive belief in
neuroscience that we can trace
all the way back to ancient greece and
plato's ideas about the human psyche
which suggests that the human brain
evolved
in layers so that you have this inner
lizard
brain which is responsible for your
instincts
like feeding and um you know
feeding and sleeping and reproducing and
so on
and that layered on top of that is a new
uh system called the limbic system which
is responsible for emotion that's found
in mammals
and then layered on top of that is
the cerebral cortex which is sometimes
referred to as the neocortex like it's a
new part that evolved
in more advanced mammals uh in
particularly
uh large in primates and in humans and
the idea is was originally that
you know the the inner your inner lizard
and your limbic system together are kind
of like this inner beast
that's responsible for all of your
less desirable characteristics less
civilized
causing you to do things and say things
that
are somewhat ill-considered and that you
probably really regret later
um and and that your neocortex is
constantly attempting to
down regulate you know wrestle to the
ground this this inner beast and so
the the metaphor is that you know your
brain is basically a battlefield between
your inner
your inner ancient beast and your more
rational evolved
self and the whole thing is basically a
myth but it's a really really
potent powerful myth that uh that even
scientists sometimes have trouble
stepping away from
so and let's just skip right to why it's
a myth is it is it just a matter of
we've looked for these different parts
of the brain and
they're not there i mean the brain does
have different parts in some sense
oh sure although you know how you divide
a brain up into parts
is um is uh really
a matter of to some extent a matter of
where you decide to draw the lines but
that's a different conversation to have
i think the
conversation that's most relevant here
is to say when you look
at a lizard brain with your naked eye
it looks as if the brain has a very
very small cerebral cortex or or no or
no cortex at all
whereas when you look at and when you
look at a rat it
looks you know a wrap brain with your
naked eye it looks as if there's a very
small cerebral cortex and when you look
at a human it looks massive
um and so this leads
has led people to believe that um
the brain evolved kind of like um
you know sedimentary rock with with
different layers evolving at different
times
but when you peer into the brain into
the
cells when you peer into the molecular
makeup of the cells and look at the
genes inside these cells what you can
see
is that there are no new neurons
essentially
that um that a lizard brain
and a wrap brain in a human brain and a
bird brain and so on
um you know in general our um
have the same types of neurons it's just
that
through evolutionary time um
you know as brains have gotten larger
and larger as bodies have gotten larger
and
larger
brains reorganize themselves so
on the outside it looks like there are
these different parts on the inside
though when you look into the
interior of the cells you can see that
you know humans have the same complement
of neurons as
a blood-sucking lamprey yeah and one of
the major issues here just to
pre-figure the rest of the conversation
is the role of
emotions in all this you know part of
this uh i guess primitive
picture that some of us have is that the
emotions are roiling
beneath us and our rational cognitive
selves
are either tamping them down or
deploying them strategically
and you have a very different view of
where emotions come from
well let me just say that my view isn't
just
a an opinion um the you know
the the uh you know the national
academies of science
sciences defines a theory as a set of
hypotheses or ideas that are backed up
by a heck of a lot of
evidence right and so what i'm about to
describe is not just it's not just my
personal opinion
it's my considered opinion um based on
um you know decades of research
uh on the anatomy and uh the
function um and the metabolics of
of the brain and to answer your question
requires me to step back a little bit
um and and make a a couple of
preliminary comments
um so that uh your listeners will
understand
the point that i'm trying to make here
and that is that
emotions um
and feelings emotions certainly are
feelings but
but but humans are also equipped to have
feelings that are not emotions
and so what do i mean by that what i
mean is that
your brain's most important job
is to regulate your body it
brains didn't evolve to think rationally
they didn't evolve to see
or feel they evolved i mean you never
can say why a brain
there's not only one reason why a brain
evolved and you can never say for sure
what that reason what what those reasons
are
but the brain's most important job
is regulating the body and as the brain
regulates the body
the body is constantly sending sense
data
about its state back to the brain
so when your heart beats when your lungs
expand as you are metabolizing glucose
in your cells
and using oxygen and so on you're not
aware of the fact that your brain
is constantly receiving sense data from
your body you don't
feel those sensations happening but that
is what's happening under the hood
so you don't the information from your
body
you don't experience it with the same
degree of fidelity that
you say see or hear or smell
or taste you don't really experience it
very often at all
in any very direct way unless
something's wrong with your body
usually you experience
what's happening in your body as very
simple feelings
of pleasantness unpleasantness feeling
calm
feeling worked up feeling comfortable
feeling uncomfortable
so evolution has fashioned us with
this kind of simple barometer of how
you know how our bodies are doing
basically um
and um that simple barometer is what
you would call feeling or mood or what a
scientist
like me would call affect effect right
affect yeah no affect feeling pleasant
unpleasant
feeling you know worked up calm affect
is with you
all the time your brain is always
regulating your body from the moment
that you're born until the moment that
you draw your last breath
and so your body's always sending
information to your brain even when
you're sleeping
and so you are always in some state of
affect your
affective feelings are properties of
consciousness in a sense they're always
with you
so but they're not emotions
in order to make affective feelings
transform them into emotions
other things have to happen and
so in a sense you know emotions are
these complex constructions that your
brain
produces out of the sense data from your
body that you
experience as affect so affect can
sometimes be transformed into emotion
but often it isn't it's
and you just have these feelings kind of
as a running
you know um you know
sort of soundscape or feelingscape that
am just as occurring um as the
background in your everyday life
and so what this means is that
you may have moments where affect is
really at the front of your
you know front of your consciousness
front of your attention you may have it
moments where you're not really paying
attention to it at all so it's sort of
in the background
but it's never you're you never have an
affectless moment in your life
so you can never be without feeling
unless
you have a non-neurotypical brain or
something is
terribly wrong and so rational moments
decision moments of of rational decision
are not moments without feeling that's
just
not possible based on the anatomy of how
our brains are structured
on the internet you can go just about
anywhere the problem is
people might be looking at where you're
going whether it's your internet service
provider
or hackers or snoopers or whatever what
you want is a bit more privacy
in the form of a vpn a virtual private
network
and private internet access pia can
provide
exactly that pia is a very simple system
to use
you can download it very easily and one
subscription will protect
up to 10 different devices at the same
time once you've installed pia
all of your web traffic goes through a
secure vpn tunnel
so your ip address is hidden and all of
your data is encrypted
you'll get a 30-day money-back guarantee
if you sign up at our mindscape listener
special url
dot com privateinternetaccess.com
mindscape by using this link
you get complete digital privacy for
less than three dollars a month
and you get three extra months for free
that's
private internet access dot com slash
mindscape
surf more securely today
and good that's a great overview of the
story and i think that we you know we
had the time to dig into it a little bit
more
deeply so why don't we start with this
idea that
uh in some sense the brain evolved
to regulate and predict behavior right
to understand you know what we should be
doing
in the world you have this wonderful
little example in the book in seven and
a half lessons
uh i forget what the little organism is
called but it's basically the little
stomach that has some nerve endings
right yeah so um
so there's a little creature the modern
creature
is called amphioxus or
its common name is lancet and
this creature has been around for you
know
i don't know five 500 million years give
her give or take
um it it really it hasn't really it's
niche
the environment that it lives in hasn't
really changed very much and so it
hasn't changed very much either and it
is considered to be
very very similar to the common ancestor
that we and other vertebrates animals
with backbones
share with invertebrates like flies and
octopuses and so on and this little
um this little it it it looks
like basically a little fish in a sense
although it has
gill slits and it it's this creature is
so interesting because it's
probably not any longer than your finger
it
it um wriggles around it has a very very
simple motor system and
very very simple sense of
touch like on on its um body
but it can't see it it can't hear it has
no ears no eyes
um it has no brain it has some of the
cells
that eventually will become um
a vertebrate brain but it is or an
invertebrate you know for animals with
brains it will eventually be
some of these cells will eventually
become a brain but but amphioxy don't
really
have brains they basically plant
themselves in the sand
sort of like a blade of grass filter
food
and then when the food concentration
decreases
the animal will uproot itself
wriggle itself to some random spot where
probabilistically there'll be more food
plant itself and
feed some more and so basically this is
an animal that doesn't really
it has no sense organs so it's not
really aware that it has an environment
at all
and it doesn't really have a brain and
and it doesn't
it to some extent doesn't really need
one because it's not really
moving around that much it's not really
moving around that much other than
you know to um to feed and
occasionally escape a predator if
if there's a looming darkness the the
animal doesn't have an
eye but it has it has the ability it has
some cells that can sense
light versus dark probably to control a
circadian rhythm
um so um it can sense darkness and when
there's a looming darkness it darts away
and that's basically what the animal is
capable of and remarkably
you know you and i and every uh animal
on this planet
um derived from an ancestor that was
somewhat like this creature
well that's the lesson that i got i mean
maybe this is too much but you
you say you have this very simple-minded
literally simple-minded if minded at all
kind of uh organism and and yet
our brains as marvelous and wonderful as
they are can we just thought of as
elaborations on this theme
that you know yeah you move when you're
running out of food and you run away
from the looming darkness and we indeed
have plenty of looming darkness around
us so maybe that makes sense
yeah for sure you know i start when i
when i started writing this book
the first set of lines i i wrote in the
first
half lesson um were you know uh
the the the earth was once ruled by
creatures without brains
and that's a biological statement not a
political statement you know because it
does sort of feel right now like you
know
is the is the world being run with
creatures that have brains
but um but the fact is that brains are
are really expensive organs to have
metabolically speaking your brain is the
most expensive
organ in your whole body and and as
over evolutionary time as um
bodies got bigger brains got bigger
and um so you know
your brain's most important job is to
regulate your body and
what you think and what you see and what
you
feel are in the service of regulating
that body
you know your body um so of course
thinking is helpful
but it's it's really in the service of
um of regulating your body and there's a
great
you know there's a this great little
meme that you know i don't know when it
started but
you know sea squirts which are um
called um tunicates which are also very
ancient
animals um uh in
um in the in our you know this um
evolutionary story these animals
actually
uh in their adult form attach to a rock
and then never move again
and then proceed to eat their own brains
basically they digest their own brains
um because you know and so so the meme
right is that this is like a model for
tenure
like what happens to professor there's
so many metaphors lurking there
underneath the ocean
right but the but the general lesson
there is that
brains are really expensive and their
their
their most important job is is
controlling your body
to keep you alive and well to figure out
when to spend resources and
when to save them so essentially you can
think of your brain
as running a budget for your body right
it's not budgeting
money it's budgeting resources like salt
and glucose and oxygen
and water and so on and every movement
that you take
every new thing that you learn
um requires energy and the assumption is
that there'll be
some return on that investment and so
your brain's always doing this very
complicated
sort of calculus to figure out um
you know which movements are worth it
when is it worth it to learn something
new versus go with what you know
right and it does kind of make sense
that rationality is as glorious as it is
is kind of an outgrowth of that it's a
some sort of optimization
puzzle solving kind of thing in fact you
deploy a vocabulary word which i'd come
across before
but felt maybe i could get away without
learning and now i feel i should learn
it which is allostasis
uh we talked to um antonio demacio whose
favorite word is homeostasis and
allostasis
is seems closely related to that but
different yeah so
allostasis so let me say homeostasis is
a very old concept
that um that certainly um
um antonio demacio is used to great
effect
and but the but the idea of of
homeostasis goes all the way back
uh to the physiologist walter cannon at
the turn of the 20th century and the
idea
is that behind around homeostasis is
that a system
has um a set point
a point where it's running most
efficiently
and like a thermostat in a sense and so
whenever there's a deviation
from that set point
the system will attempt to return itself
to that set point because it's most
most efficient at that set point
and it's a very reactive model of how
things work so there's a change and then
the brain responds to that change by
attempting to return to the set point
what we know though is first of all
that brains and and in fact many
biological systems run by prediction
not by um reaction so
your brain is not sitting around dormant
waiting for stuff to happen and then
reacting to it that is
incredibly metabolically inefficient and
metabolic efficiency is actually a major
constraint on brain evolution
and on the health of individual
creatures like you and me
so instead what's happening is that your
brain is attempting to
predict the needs of the body and meet
those needs before they arise
so for example your brain doesn't stand
you up
and then change your blood pressure to
get oxygen to your brain
that would be metabolically costly
you know to put it mildly because you'd
probably faint and break a limb
but instead what happens is as your
brain is preparing to stand you up it
also changes your blood pressure so that
as you stand
you right and so allostasis
is the predictive regulation of the body
allostasis is literally defined as
attempting to
um anticipate the needs of the body and
meet those needs before they arise
that's literally the definition of
allostasis
and also the assumption is that it's not
that you're trying to
reduce spending it's that you're trying
well you are trying to reduce spending
but
you're trying to be efficient in your
spending meaning you can be out of
statically balanced when you're running
on a treadmill you can be allostatically
balanced when you're sitting quietly
at your desk the point is that your your
brain is attempting to get your body
into the most
efficient window or the most efficient
range
of functioning because efficiency
is is um is what's important so
for example when you exercise i don't
know if you work out at the gym
or if you you know work out with
trainers or whatever but
if you start learning a new
exercise you're you know it takes a lot
of effort
and um uh and
you know you might not be very good at
it and but as you practice
right you start to get better and better
and you get you know you develop muscle
memory
and you you start to become much more
efficient at doing that exercise
um and um that's really great when
you're playing tennis
but it really sucks if you're trying to
keep yourself in cardiovascular
health because what you want to do is is
maximally
you know exercise your heart and so
interval training is really great for
this because you're constantly changing
what you do
all the time this is a great
illustration of allostasis
if you keep doing the same exercise over
and over and over again you're going to
get
better and better and better at it more
efficient more efficient more efficient
at it because your brain is
allostatically adjusting to it
and the reason why interval training
works so great
is that you know the minute the brain is
starting to allostatically adjust
your trainer changes your exercise
program that's great i mean
it's actually quite rare that we get uh
actionable advice here on the mindscape
podcast we're
more about big picture theories of the
world but this is actually news you can
use which which is
something a little bit different um and
and
this theme i guess it brings me back i
did have a conversation also with carl
fristen right who has his free energy
principle
um again and again i in slightly
different
angles we get this theme that life is
hard and there's an infinite number of
things that could happen to us
and so the brain figures out schemes
that are basically shortcuts right that
are sort of
um ways to do a pretty good job maybe
not the best possible job but
make us more efficient than we would be
just by blind
flailing around yeah i think that's
putting i think that's the right the
right vibe i think that's putting it
really mildly though
i i guess what i would say is you know
and i'll
i'll i think that um there philosophers
and neuroscientists and some
electrical engineers might care about
the difference between allostasis and
free energy
um but for what i'm about to say um you
know
carl is trying to take things um right
down to the level of physics which i'm
sure you appreciate
i'm i'm happy to stay at the level of
biology
um and um probably because you know i
got a c
in high school physics and i couldn't
even get through my college course i'm
you know so um uh i'm just
just confessing there um um but i i
think
i think generally yeah here the point
really is
that the world is filled with
ambiguous sense data
if you think about it um you know your
brain is
is trapped in a dark silent box
for your whole life called your skull
and it's receiving
sense data from you know from the world
through your
your sense organs your eyes your ears
your nose and so on
and it's receiving sense data from your
body and these are the effects
of some set of causes but your brain
doesn't know the causes it only knows
the effects
so that's a classic problem that
philosophers call
a reverse inference problem or an
inverse inference problem
you know the effects but you have to
guess at the cause
so you're constantly faced with um
input that you actually don't know
what caused it so you don't know what to
do about it to keep you
alive and well and so your brain
has one other source of information
that's available
and that is what's happened in the past
under similar circumstances and
in science this is how you know i don't
know if this is how it works in physics
but
in psychology and in neuroscience the
way that you know that something is
important is that
every time someone discovers it they
give it they give it a new name
so some people call this memory some
people call it perceptual
inference some people call it simulation
there are lots and lots and lots of
names for what i'm about to describe but
basically
if we were to freeze time right now
and look at what your brain is doing
it's it's got some representation
of what is going on in its in your body
and what's going on
you in the world and maybe the
trajectory
of change that brought you there and
it's asking itself
metaphorically the last time
i was confronted with this array of
sense data
what caused it what did i do
what did i smell what did i see what did
i hear what did i feel
so it's basically conjuring
in its own wiring re-implementing
past experiences that are somewhat
similar
to the present conditions in order to
predict what's going to happen next
and the remarkable thing about this
from my perspective because i'm just
like um
uh i am a very very very skeptical
person so
i it took me 25 years to even believe my
own data let alone you know so i just
don't
i'm not easily swayed but the thing that
really i found remarkable about this is
that
i was reading in work on neuroanatomy
and then i was reading work on signal
processing um
and then i was reading other work on in
electrophysiology
and other work in functional brain
function and nervous system function and
they all point
to the same idea even though
those literatures don't talk to each
other at all and that is that your brain
is basically
using the past to predict the future as
a way of controlling
your body and creating your experience
in the present
this is very um something i can be very
sympathetic to as a physicist who's
interested in the arrow of time you know
not
not to keep name-dropping past podcasts
but we also had one with janae and
ismael who is a
philosopher of science who thinks about
exactly this why we think that we have
choices and free will and so forth and
it has a lot to do with projecting
what's going to happen in the immediate
past and recalling the immediate future
but i think but i think that's a whole
other podcast because we need to get to
emotions
somehow and we're very close
so great we have this brain uh it's
doing its best to
um to get along in the world without
wasting too many resources
and it gets as you said both um external
sense data but also
is enteroception the right word uh for
this
model for this this uh idea that the
the brain has about what is internal
body state is doing yes so you can think
about
you know if you use this idea of the
brain in the box right
then from the brain's perspective the
periphery
is its body in the world your body
is a part of the environment that the
brain is trying to guess at
and so um the
you know the sense data that you know
come that we
experience as vision and touch and so on
we call exteroceptive and the sense data
that come from the body
is called interoceptive sometimes people
mistake interception for
the awareness of those sense data but
really
it interception is this
is the um the brain's modeling of the
sensory environment of the body meaning
your brain needs to make
guesses about what your heart is doing
what your lungs are doing
what you know where the glucose needs to
be
where more oxygen versus carbon dioxide
is and so on and so forth so
um your brain is using sense data
interceptive data
from the body to help model the body in
order to figure out
what you know how to control it and what
what to do next
and your brain is always doing this your
your whole life every
waking moment of your life and every
moment that you're asleep
this is going on all the time and then
sometimes
your brain will um make sense of those
data so when you're
when you're you know you don't see
separately from
um hearing separately from smelling to
us it feels like our senses are very
distinct but actually at the level of
the brain
you know the senses are to some extent
speaking to one another
um and um scientists call this um
you know neuroscientists call this
multi-modality that you're
and so interception is all tied up with
vision and audition and and and touch
and so on it's it's like this
intimate dance between the senses that's
always happening
all the time so for example
literally what you see is influenced by
the state of your body
you may not realize that but it is
actually
and there are many many studies which
but certainly the anatomy
clearly points to this but also there
are very many functional studies
um that that show it and so you know
the way to explain how emotions are made
is the following so
your brain at every moment is asking
itself
what is similar to the present sensory
array
what is similar to the presence not what
is this not what are these sense data
but what's similar to this
in my past in
psychology things that are similar to
one another
are called a category
and the representation of a category is
called a concept
okay so you you could say that what your
brain is doing when it's predicting what
it's doing
is category construction or concept
construction
your brain is conjuring a concept as a
set of predictions
about the possible meaning
of sense data that is about to arrive
at your brain to your brain so it's
making guesses
hypotheses about what's about to happen
and what caused it
if i hear a russell so if i hear a
wrestling i don't mean to go on and on
it's but it's
it's really no please it's really more
complicated than
you know the idea that you have a fear
circuit in your um
lizard brain you know um that gets
triggered and then proof you know you
you're fearful and it's unfortunately it
takes more words to
to describe this but the idea would be
you know you're walking
in the woods say and you hear a rustle
of leaves and
you hear the rust of leaves and so if
you stop stop time
and you look at what's happening in the
brain the brain is going to be
asking itself what is similar in my past
to the the sensory array right now
and your past isn't just the stuff
that's exp
you've experienced it's also stuff that
you've read about or experiences you've
had watching movies or
somebody telling you something um or you
know things that you've observed and so
your brain might predict that it's the
wind or it might predict that
it's a snake or it might predict that
um something fell from a tree
or it might predict that it's a person
with a gun
or it might predict your brain could be
predicting lots of things and it's
predicting more than one thing
and these predictions
are our concepts their
their knowledge that you have based on
past experience about what's likely to
happen next and so your brain actually
starts to prepare
your body to it prepares your heart and
your lungs and the internal systems of
your body
to support whatever action your brain is
believing that it should take so it's
sort of weighing probabilities
trying to figure out which one is is the
right one and then it begins to
prepare your action and
when this and the the it begins to also
prepare your
your the anticipated sense data that
that will come next
so what did i hear the last time i
prepared this action what is the last
did i see the last time what did i smell
the last time how did i feel the last
time
and so your brain's actually preparing
these changing the firing of its own
neurons to prepare this response
and then the sense data come in and if
the sense data match
the prediction then the response just
executes
and to you it feels like you're just
reacting to stuff in the world
but actually there's been a lot of
preparation under the hood
um so when your brain conjures past
experience
to make sense of sense data
it's constructing a concept if it
constructs an emotion concept
then you it makes an emotion if it
constructs some other kind of concept
um then it can is in constructing some
other kind of experience
yeah i mean i think this is fascinating
because i understand
the sort of intellectual version of this
or the conceptual version where we say
you know
i look at a picture on my computer
screen and rather than just seeing it as
a thousand by thousand array of pixels
with different color values i say oh
look there's a puppy or something like
that right i
i coarse grain it in that way to give my
myself a concept that goes along with
all sorts of other concepts
but the and that i think most of us can
can sort of easily grasp but you're
bringing in this extra element which is
that
emotions are an example of that and in
particular
an example that we use to help the body
decide what actions to take is that a
fair way of saying it
that's absolutely the right way of
saying it so
there's so much embedded in in what i'm
saying there's so many implications for
people's everyday lives that
which i wrote about actually in my book
called how emotions are made the secret
life of the brain where i
explain this in great detail it's a
popular science book so
um you know if you want to know it in
the really nitty gritty detail you have
to go to the scientific papers but
you know it's a popular science book and
so it has some amount of detail
and it also has a set of implications um
and i've
i've given demonstrations in many of the
talks
to the public that i've given um about
how this works which
um listeners can find on my um public
website
lisa feldman barrett.com um
where you can demonstrate how
concepts work you know concepts are not
this like laundry list
of features um you know to describe
something right so if i asked you like
uh what's a cat
you know um or what's a bird you know
you might give me a set of features
that you think a bird has like you know
wings and
feathers and of course but the thing is
that
not all birds have wings and not all
birds have feathers
and in fact research shows that when you
ask someone
to tell you the concept of a bird
they're what they're doing really is
they're imagining
um an instance of a bird
so if i ask you sean tell me tell me um
the features of a bird what kind of bird
does your mind conjure in that moment
right there's some sort of standard bird
which is probably for me something like
a crow
okay a crow that's interesting a lot of
people say like a robin or
but a crow we can go the crow you can
blame game of thrones for this
i'm sorry we can blame game of thrones
for this i presume
right no that's right that's great
actually
and if but if the if you're in a pet
store
and your goal is to um
uh to buy a pet bird
what kind of bird would your would your
brain conjure
right now i'm look thinking of it like a
little um
oh i forget what they're called the
little budgies the little uh yeah like a
yeah a little budgie right exactly
and if i if you were sitting at the
thanksgiving dinner table
and you were hungry and the bird was
serving as a function
its function was food what kind of bird
would you
would you conjure oh you've chosen a
terrible example because my wife uh
jennifer and i always have peking duck
on thanksgiving but
for you it's peaking duck that's
actually that's a great example because
for me
it would be um it would be turkey
and um the really interesting thing
right is that the experiences that you
have over and over and over again like
both of us watching game of thrones um
uh
actually changes which which concepts
that your brain
makes like the the experiences that you
have today
um become the predictions
of tomorrow you know i mean basically
you are cultivating continually your
past as a means of controlling your
future
you are the experiences you have today
become
the past that your brain uses to make
predictions for tomorrow
so the point here though is that
when your brain makes a concept it's not
making a laundry list of features that's
static that's used again and again and
again in all
in all situations your brain is making a
situated concept
it's like whatever the function of a
bird is in a given situation that's the
that's the um the prediction that your
brain is making
and it's true also for emotion so for
example
if i ask you what you know what this if
i ask you what is anger
what are the features of anger you
you're you live in
you're from a western culture and you
probably know the western stereotype of
anger
um which is you know well tell me what
do you think anger is
what's anger uh it's an emotion where
you're very upset and you're directing
that upsettedness at
um a person or an event that has done
something wrong
okay so somebody has harmed you and um
and it's it's unpleasant and um you're
really worked up
and um and you're likely to
do what uh
react badly against them okay do
something to hurt them
to harm them and how how does your face
look
scrunched up and maybe turning red yeah
so you're scowling and your blood
pressure's rising
and you're you're turning red okay so
that's the stereotype
of um just like a crow for you as a
stereotype
of a bird or for me you know might be a
robin
um that's this that's the western
stereotype of anger
so the data show
that about 30 of the time people do
scowl in the west
um people do scowl in anger
which means that's statistically more
than chance so
um you know that gets you a publication
in a in a
good journal um but what it means is
that
70 of the time your face is doing
something else other than
scouting 100 yeah that's meaningful too
right sometimes we cry in anger
sometimes we laugh
in anger or smile and anger sometimes we
frown in anger sometimes our faces are
completely still in anger
your your brain is preparing using
concepts is preparing your actions that
are situated that are
um important you know they're the action
that will best work in a situation that
you're in
so similarly your blood pressure does go
up in anger sometimes
but it also goes down sometimes and
sometimes it stays the same
and sometimes anger really the
the function of anger is really to
um uh cause harm
um to someone else who's harmed you
but sometimes anger brings people
together
sometimes the function of anger is to
make you feel part of a group
sometimes anger helps you um compete
better
sometimes it helps you win a debate or a
soccer match
so anger sometimes anger is pleasant um
it's not always unpleasant
so um the the the point here is that
just in the way that birds change their
features depending on the functions that
they're serving this is also true
of of emotion um categories of the
instances of emotion so the instances of
anger
are not one thing with one pattern
there is a population of instances your
brain can make many
concepts for anger and that means that
it can control your body
in very in ways that are tied very
closely to the situation
in flexible ways um to allow you to
to deal with the situation so
essentially emotions are not your
reactions
to the world they're they are your
brain's construction
of what the sense data
mean in your bo well you get the sense
data in your body what they mean
what what what their meaning is relative
to what's going on around you in the
world and it's a prescription for
action about what you should do next
to deal with that situation
i really liked the uh i think that it
was you who made this analogy sorry if i
if i'm getting it from somewhere else
but the analogy
with uh how different people perceive
colors right
there's um uh physicists can think about
colors as different
spectra and wavelengths of light and so
forth but real human beings
have the ability to perceive different
colors and they're going to see two
things that are almost exactly the same
wavelength and call them the same color
so there's some core screening that goes
on
and it's real it's you know it there's
overlap from person to person
but it's not absolutely objective and
universal different people will
do it in a slightly different way and
this kind of maps on
and it maps on to the idea that emotions
are not like uh
there's an anger circuit and a fear
circuit in your brain and you can go and
poke those neurons it's something that
is
that is a little more plastic a little
bit more developing a little bit more uh
socially constructed than that
absolutely i mean i think that the
you know how emotions are made um the
the the framework the theoretical
framework and the evidence to support it
really is
um a neuroscience explanation
for social construction
you know we we this is something that i
i deal with in
seven and a half lessons about the brain
too it's really the
well it comes up in a couple of lessons
but it's really the topic of the
final lesson and that is that
much of what we think of as the natural
world the physical world
is actually created by us and what i
mean by that is
um that
you know we
humans have this capacity uh
that no other animal has as far as we
know
which is to create what's called social
reality
it's to take something physical
and impose a function on it that it
doesn't
have by virtue of its physical nature
but if we all agree
that it has that function um then it
then it takes on that function only by
virtue of our agreement
so the perfect example of this is money
right different things have served um
as currency things like
you know paper plastic
the promise of the promise of of um
paper in the future which is a mortgage
you know um
for the promise of money in the future
um salt
diamonds barley big rocks
uh in the um in the ocean that don't
move
bitcoin i mean all of these things
basically if if they only derive their
value by virtue of what's called
collective agreement
a bunch of humans agree that this thing
can be traded for material goods and
poof it has value
if humans these humans that then did
you know decide that this can no longer
be traded for material goods or some
people withdraw their consent then
poof it no longer has value that's it i
mean basically
you know money is a is the perfect
example of social reality because it's
um
it's so malleable in this way it's like
a collective
you know illusion that we all create
together by virtue of um
our agreement to impose a function
on something physical that the thing
doesn't have
by its physical nature but it's very
real for all of that it has enormous
power and causal influence in the world
oh my goodness it has tremendous causal
influence and in fact you can stick
someone's head in a brain scanner
and you know have them earn little um
you know pieces of money and you get you
get very real
brain activity uh changes you know based
on money
so um but the point here is that um
that that much of much of what we
much of our everyday lives is is um
influenced by in civilization by things
that we ourselves have constructed and
imposed meaning on
and so for example a wide-eyed gasping
stare in the west is considered to be
the stereotypic expression of fear
and there are scientists who will give
you some
[Music]
concocted evolutionary tale about
why this is the case the only problem
with it
is that um in many parts of the world
that is not that
that facial configuration is a
configuration of threat
like when you want to threaten someone
you want to threaten them
with harm that's the face that you make
so there's no
you know there's no
there's nothing specifically
meaningful in a physical sense about any
facial expression per se
it's that we have i mean in a
psychological sense
we have imposed meaning on it and
if you and i share that meaning we agree
that that movement has that meaning in
this context
then that makes me more predictable to
you
and it makes you more predictable to me
and
that reduces the metabolic burden
on our brains because things that are
predictable
are just less expensive metabolically
speaking
and so there's a real advantage
to having things be predictable
it very much is sympathetic with the
uh or analogous i guess to the physics
concepts of emergence in some sense
where you have
um a way of talking about a system which
is
vastly simpler than all of the data that
you might uh
imagine is required yet nevertheless
gives you a really strong handle on
what's going to happen my favorite
example is
just the center of mass of a planet
right if you want to know how the earth
goes around the sun
you don't need to keep track of all the
10 to the 50th atoms in the earth you
need relatively little amounts of
information and this
this this idea seems to be
if i i always worry that i'm sort of
over physicizing things but it seems to
be
that you're saying that emotions are
kind of a
a handle on the world that allows
the brain to convert impulses into
action
in a way that is not absolutely
determined by the world
out there but is a shortcut that allows
us to
get by in a more efficient way
absolutely i think the main
the main thing to understand though is
that
it only works when when you're in a
context where other people share the
same
concepts as you yeah right because
because emotion concepts are concepts of
social reality
so um you know the analogy
for example to to color categories i
think is really apt
um uh you don't always experience
light at a particular you know light
at a particular wavelength as a
particular color
you know it depends on the context that
you're in
and actually it also depends on the
concepts that you have
that your brain is able to make so
concepts aren't these like
abstract things
um they are very very sensory and motor
so for example
um if i um ask you
and if you keep your eyes open and
look at some you know focus on something
in the room keep your eyes open and but
in your mind's eye
imagine um an apple of the kind that you
would eat
like a red macintosh apple
can you can you do that i can yes
okay and imagine grasping that apple
and imagine um
taking a bite of that apple can you hear
the crunch of the apple
can you taste the tartness of the apple
i can yes my eyes are closed i'm
imagining all these things okay
so you've just created the concept of an
apple of a macintosh apple that's what a
concept is it's actually changing the
firing of your own
neurons so that you can see a ghostly
apple
you can um you know
get the the gist of a taste of that
apple
you can hear the crunch of the apple um
you know if i had your hat and a brain
scanner um
we would with your eyes closed um we
would see changes in
early visual cortex the neurons that are
are
important for vision we'd see changes in
um
the parts of the brain that are
important for moving your body we'd see
changes in
the parts of your body that prepare
parts of your brain that prepare your
body to eat
um we would see all of these changes
um uh even though
your eyes are closed you're not eating
anything you know even if i just say the
word apple
that we can see these changes happen in
someone's brain
and they're happening in your brain as i
speak words
which are communicating concepts and as
you speak words and communicate concepts
to me they're happening in my brain
that's how we
we perform essentially mental telepathy
on each other when we communicate where
we're planting um
or sort of sending or lobbing concepts
at each other
these concepts are not abstract things
they they
literally your brain remarkably is
changing the firing of its own neurons
to prepare for incoming sense data
so that's what you're doing when you
like when you have um
a song going through your head that you
cannot get out of your head no matter
what you do
that is the same process neurally
as um a prediction
or making a concept um when someone has
tinnitus
and they hear the scent the the
frequency of sound that that they've
in their head that they've lost um
the ability to hear from the world
that's also
something very equivalent to prediction
um i have this great like making a
concept i have this great
um gift that someone shared with me
which i now use in
my talks all the time which is this um
it's a movie of a um
a jumping of a electrical tower playing
jump rope
and when people look at it you know i
use it to sort of explain
how concepts work because when you look
at the at first you can see that it's
it's electrical towers playing jump rope
and so this shows us a couple of things
one thing it shows us is that
the way that your brain makes concepts
is um
what we would call generative or meaning
your brain can take bits and pieces of
past experience
and combine it in new ways so that you
can experience something that you've
never experienced before
like if you ever in your real life ever
seen electrical towers playing jump rope
no but you can immediately understand
that that's what you're looking at
because you've yeah okay and then but
the really cool thing about it
is even though there's no sound this is
just a black and white
movie that is silent you can hear
the towers bumping as they hit the
ground and you can
feel the vibration in your chest
huh and i guess that makes sense because
in some sense
i mean one of the many lessons i get
from conversations like this is that
there's less of a difference between
what happens inside our brain when we
experience sensory input from the
outside world and
when we imagine that input then we might
think similar things are happening in
the brain
yeah exactly when you're dreaming when
you're imagining
when you are actually perceiving what's
going on in the world
very very very similar things are
actually happening under the hood
exactly and so when i say your brain is
making a concept or it's
creating a prediction it's changing the
firing of its own neurons
your brain is changing the firing of
your neurons to prepare you to act
completely outside of your awareness and
with great you know
very quick and very automatically um
it's preparing um to
you to your body to um
act in a particular way and it's also
preparing
the it's inferring or guessing
what are you if you if you act in this
way what are you likely to hear
what are you likely to see what are you
likely to feel because
there will have been changes inside your
body it's preparing these
in exactly the same way as it conjured
an
apple um with sights and sounds and
and tastes and so on one of the
issues that is always comes up in these
conversations is the free will
question or the you know amount of
control we have over ourselves and i got
this
wonderful sentence from one of your
papers where you say
actual executive control and the feeling
of being in control are not
synonymous but i think that they can
both be there
it's just that this feeling of control
is a little bit different than the
actual control to whatever extent we
have that
yeah so this is a really this is a
really tricky
problem i would say um you know in
psychology and in neuroscience and
maybe it's there in other sciences too i
don't know but
we have common sense we have words that
mean things in
common sense in everyday parlance and
then we have
sometimes people you scientists will use
the same words
to mean something technical and
that makes people mistakenly believe
that the words are referring to the same
thing when they're not
so oh yeah we know yeah so so you have a
set of
we all have a set of neurons connected a
network of neurons connected in our
in our brains that um that
help to select
which inputs we will care about
which sense data will care about and
which
actions which predictions will be
completed
um and these are called you know the
control network
uh but they work all the time in fact
they probably they're relaxed when
you're sleeping
somewhat and they're relaxed if you take
psilocybin
um or ketamine um but
you know so you can chemically relax
them or you can chemically enhance them
um by you know taking an amphetamine um
or um you know something that will
enhance dopamine say
um so you can or or norepinephrine you
can you can enhance them or you can
you can diminish them but but they're
never off
um and your experience of control of
being in control
is not related particularly to
the function of these neurons right so
your all of this stuff that's happening
prediction
and selection and for the most part is
happening
without your awareness and without any
sense of agency
uh or control on without any sense of
agency or control on your part
then a feeling of control on your part
um
and usually when we're talking about
free will
you know i i mean free will is a you
know it's a big topic that
that i've noticed yes scholars have been
debating
um since um there have been scholars to
debate
and of course i don't i don't really
think of myself as an expert in
in this regard but i will say this that
the traditional idea
of of free will
people who p scholars writers thinkers
who've
questioned the traditional notion of
free will
are probably correct that that doesn't
mean that you have no control over your
behavior
and it doesn't mean that you are not
responsible for your behavior
but the traditional notion of free will
um is i think you know questionable
um um but you do have
i think and this is something i talk
about in how emotions are made and it's
also something
that i elaborate on in them seven and a
half lessons
um about the brain you we do have
control over our behavior and we are
responsible for our behavior but
the manner of that control
you know looks a little different than
than
common sense might lead us to believe
right and that's definitely one of the
implications of this kind of research
for
you know as we as i joked about before
sort of practical
everyday uh actionable information that
we can get but
but there's others right i mean you you
talk about
the fact that um tech companies are
trying to read people's emotions on
their faces like
and i was a big fan of the tv show lie
to me where tim roth would just be able
to know
everything about you by looking at micro
expressions but if this view of emotions
as
not hardwired and affected by social
reality is
true then that's going to be a much
trickier
uh task than we might have guessed
yes there's so much to say about that
sean honestly
um so the but maybe the simplest thing
to say
is this facial movements
are not a language to be read the way
like words on a page um
when you look at someone your brain is
making a guess
about what those facial movements mean
and
um and you're get the brain is guessing
it's inferring
automatically and effortlessly but it's
nonetheless inferring
based on the context that's occurring
not just spatially
not just spatially but also temporally
and not just
outside your body but also inside your
body so uh
the part of the context for inferring
the meaning of facial movements in
somebody else is what's happening inside
your own body in that moment
and what's occurred um previously so
um and i should say that you know i
one of the best experiences i had i've
had really as a scientist
was i
i was asked with four other scientists
all of us senior scientists
all of us coming from very different
theoretical
positions on the nature of emotion so
very different priors
um and some of us didn't know each other
uh in advance or at least had not met in
person
and we met for two and a half years
every week on
zoom this was before the pandemic um
we read over a thousand papers
um about emotional expressions in adults
in children in
um you know neurotypical adults in in
children
in um you know people who are born
congenitally blind in people who are
from
you know urban cultures and from remote
um
cultures that are you know much somewhat
more um secluded
uh not completely secluded but somewhat
more distant from
you know western cultural practices and
norms
um in people from the huds of people who
are hunters gatherers in
sub-saharan africa and um and so on and
so forth so
really a huge um literature um
and we all all of us
despite our you know starting positions
we all came to consensus around what the
data showed
and in two cases this was a major change
for the scientists involved in their
views
about emotional expressions because the
data clearly show
that
scowls are
one expression of anger but they are not
the expression of anger they're not even
the dominant expression of anger
smiling is one expression of happiness
but it's not
the expression of happiness and so on
and so forth you
as i said before you know the davis show
that you scowl about people scale about
30
of the time in in western cultures
um even in eastern cultures if they're
urban cultures
um in large countries um then you know
people scowl about 30 of the time
they're meaningfully doing something
else with their face about 70 of the
time that's low reliability
it's not zero but it's low and people
scowl when they're not
angry they scowl when they're confused
they scowl when they're concentrating
really hard they scowl when you tell
them a bad joke they scowl when they
have gas
that's low specificity so
uh you know 30 of the time
better than chance may be good enough to
get a publication in the proceedings of
the national academy of sciences
and it may be good enough if you're if
you're
if you want to use this kind of
technology
to um you know to try to sell something
to someone
but the best software
what it can do is it can detect scowling
but not
tell you what scowling means right and
what companies are doing right now is
they're
they're confusing the observation
of a movement with its with its meaning
with its emotional meaning
and that may be fine when all you're
doing is someone trying to sell somebody
something because what's the worst that
can happen they don't buy it and you
lose money
but when you are making judgments
that will affect the outcomes of real
lives like who gets to go to what school
whether someone is charged with a a
crime or found guilty of that crime
whether um you know you get hired or not
yeah i was just saying exactly the same
thing as you whether someone should be
hired for a job or not yeah
then it becomes a really really serious
matter and
one of the points that we make in the
paper
um that we wrote together um is that we
um that you know when we talk about
interpreting a face in context we don't
mean
measuring one or two other signals like
okay you can also measure people's body
movements and maybe measure their voice
or maybe measure their heart rate that's
really not what
your brain is using when your brain
looks at someone
and makes an inference very
automatically and effortlessly about
what that facial movement means
your brain is using high dimensional
data
lots and lots and lots of signals that
are spatially
and temporally um creating this
you know really elaborate context so
emergence is not a bad metaphor
for for what is happening here and
as far as i know no one is doing
research
uh quite like that you know
um although we've been recommending it
for some time
actually well we always like to uh spin
what we say here on the podcast as
advice to
uh young people in high school and
college now who are deciding what to do
so that if they
they're good open research directions uh
then by all means recommend them to the
young people out there yeah
here's what i'll say i'll say that you
know um
that uh one of the reasons why
um the theory of constructed emotion or
constructionism more generally you know
people you know scholars used to make
this distinction between
um you know um like
evolutionary theories about the brain um
which were heavily biological and then
social constructivist theories which are
were
you know didn't care about biology at
all and and only you know we're
concerned about
like cultural influences and one of the
interesting things about the fear of
constructed emotion is that
it's looking at it's really giving a a
an evolutionary and biological um
foundation to how the brain constructs
every experience you have
and every action that you take and
yeah it really it's it's providing a
a framework that can integrate
you know uh
evidence from molecular genetics and
um and other forms of biology
uh all the way up to you know cultural
inheritance
and um in anthropology and questions in
sociology so it's a really it's a broad
broad broad framework and
i'm speaking directly to young people
when i say this it's a really really
exciting
time to be asking questions about the
human mind and human experience and
human action because
this perspective opens up a ton of new
questions that weren't there before
you know sometimes progress in science
isn't answering old questions it's
asking
newer better questions and that's really
what this perspective allows you to do
and that in some way is why i wrote
seven and a half lessons about the brain
because you know in my mind
science is incredibly fun and it's
really really interesting
and um you know it allows you to be
curious and experience
wonder almost on a daily basis i mean
it's it's a it's a wonderful career
but science along with philosophy are
also tools for living
tools for living your best life i i
don't mean that in some kind of airy
fairy way i mean that
honestly in an authentically real way
they are tools for living your best life
and the job of a scientist
of some scientists of some of us right
sean is to try to distill
the technically complicated stuff
into some usable nuggets
for people who
don't make science their profession on a
day-to-day basis
and that can happen in a podcast it can
happen in a book of essays it can happen
in a classroom it can happen
in a self-help book it can happen all
over the place but
one of the reasons why i wrote the book
was
i wanted to just take some nuggets
of neuroscience that i thought were
particularly fascinating
and use them to invite people
to think about big questions regarding
human nature
and not really to tell people what kind
of a human to be
but to get people to think about
you know who who do you want to be like
what kind of a person do you want to be
how do you want to how do you wanna live
in this world
what do you want your impact to be on
other people
because understanding how your brain
works as it's having this continuous
conversation with your body in the
you know world surrounded by other
brains and bodies
this is the world that you live in and
so understanding a little bit more about
brains
you know helps you make decisions that
are a little more
deliberate about you know who you want
to be and what kind of impact you want
to have on other people
well you've come to the right podcast i
couldn't agree more with everything you
just said and it's so perfect that i
i think that uh we can't improve upon
that as a as a
place to end the conversation so lisa
feldman barrett thanks so much for being
on the mind ski podcast
it's been my absolute pleasure thank you
so much for having me on your show
[Music]
you